hi everybody it's a it's an honor to be
here I'm glad to be here thank you too
now heat for organizing this panel and
it's a real honor to present in front of
so many people who have been
inspirational to me so um the title of
my talk today is the Iranian popular
music and the politics of impiety I'll
focus on diaspora and I'll say that you
know giving a talk at the end of a
conference that's been mostly on this on
a set of contained subjects is helpful
in some ways but may lead to some
redundancies what I hope is that it will
actually be a nice way to connect many
of the things that we've been talking
about over over the last couple of days
so this talk is about tarantulas Tara
Angeles as most of you know refers to
the expatriate Iranian popular culture
industries that grew up in Southern
California beginning in the late 1970s
the product of a mass exodus of popular
musicians journalists media
personalities and other creative types
from Iran around the time of the
Revolution for the nearly two decades
when popular music was not permitted in
Iran Tehran Julis was the world's sole
mass producer of Persian language
popular music many famous
pre-revolutionary vocalists songwriters
and lyricists who first came to national
consciousness in the 1960s and 70s then
became exiles in Southern California
where they acquired a new identity as
Los Angeles see so Los Angeles see is an
epithet it's a negative term and people
who live there do not necessarily
appreciate being called this term in
part because the assertion is that they
are not Yanni anymore they are Los
Angeles E as if they have to split off
and become another another branch so
this this sort of this assertion of
separation that's especially given to
them by people who don't live there who
are not part of this community is in
some ways unfair because the Iranian
diasporic music industry in Los Angeles
is one of the most highly if not the
most highly developed expatriate music
industries in the world that can boast a
relationship with its home country maybe
we could think of Thai
exiles who left I mean mainland China
and went to Taiwan or maybe we could
think of Vietnamese who went to Orange
County and also in both cases music back
to their home countries but the
situation of expatriates in in Los
Angeles is is rather unique not that
this has amounted to respect necessarily
for most Angeles musicians because
everyone can agree and many of you have
already told me over the course of the
past couple of days that this is bad
music bad it's bad for lots of people
it's bad for cultural elites it's bad
for snobs it's bad for classical
musicians
and it's also bad according to the
post-revolutionary Iranian government in
official Islamic Republic discourse
expatriate Angeles cultural producers
who left around the time of the
revolution are sometimes called Ferrari
escapees people who didn't serve their
time they are quarterback machines
sitting in exile separate from
contemporary Iran and irrelevant to it
or sometimes they are agents in the
softwar who's helped spread corruption
via expatriate media like to Angeles
dance instructor and you know just
absolute phenomenon Mohammad Fleur de
yong who was arrested and charged with
these crimes when he visited Iran in
2002 this kind of narration of people in
exile continues musicians in exile
continues in March of just last year
2017 the Iranian Revolutionary Court
number 7 their 28th sentence boo-boo-chh
in absentia to 16 years in prison for
propaganda against the Islamic Republic
and for creating Matic is a facade so
centers of corruption and corrupting the
public more generally these punishments
are on the basis of you know if if we're
going to if if we can bracket for a
moment the idea that I know is common
that these kinds of religious reasonings
are used cynically we can put that to
the side for a second they are you can
see these as based on the supposed
influence of music musicians and media
to effects moral disorder and political
unrest among audiences and are in a way
an assertion of musicians
and Western powers and media's almost
metaphysical power Western governments
are also ideologically and financially
committed to this idea we wouldn't have
music programming on VOA BBC Persian
audio fader or other Western state
sponsored media outlets without this
similar idea nor would review a fat
dollop on surd Google Isha's concerts
and Dubai
as they did in 2013 3 2003 excuse me
this apparent power and relevance
competes with an equally and
increasingly prevalent scenario
sentiment that Los Angeles popular
musicians are irrelevant embarrassing
and a joke so there is a song by Zedd
buzzie called aronia la la where they
talk about musicians in Los Angeles as
making Mousavi or bacteria beat or so
naughty
and that they're mostly but Bhoomi de
batata Scooby de toilettes II so their
music their music is just it's terrible
music that's being made by exiles on
traditional beats meaning the rip it's
repetitive 6/8 beat that's very common
to moistur repertoire and their music
actually smells worse than
government-issued could be the kebab a
notoriously smelly ground meat and onion
dish rappers shahin najafi goes further
in calling tehran to those musicians
Mantovani vats and foolish or Mahtob
pimping home
excuse me homeland pimping woodshed and
this kind of dispersion also has cast on
scholars studying this music as i'm sure
professor shake and can relate to I just
relate a quick story that I was at a
party once
actually with idem IFTA he in Toronto in
2006 and everyone was dancing and having
a good time she introduced me to a
famous journalist whose name I will not
to mention and she said this
she's pretty soon she's going to Los
Angeles to to study the music there and
he looked at me dead serious and said
past me why should she not see before
Nene called man she's an awesome Irish
[ __ ] she knows I'm a [ __ ] ologist in
this case right so I must study somebody
who studies this so anytime this this
kind of negative intense negative
reaction occurs around something we know
that something interesting is going on
tarantulas music and media producers are
conscious of these circulating negative
dismissive assessments from from these
various parties and and they also
recognize themselves as aging and less
relevant to Iranian audiences them in
Prior decades but they are protective of
their position in Iranian history after
the Revolution because they saved
popular music now as the and this is the
this is the discourse that is often
assisted that they often promulgate the
revolution gave them a purpose without
it they would just be aging pop singers
but in this case they have attached
themselves to a kind of cultural mission
so I consider the Tanner angeles music
industry as one of the revolutions
unintended consequences in my past work
I've conceptualized heterogeneous
cultural formations as alternatives to
culture and identity and the Islamic
Republic of Iran that are forwarded
through a sort of alternative public
sphere now this has been a synergistic
relationship selling what's not
available in us or and what's not
available in Iran as a business strategy
but also a political kind of orientation
so I want to talk about one aspect of
that idea here and think about Tehran
jealous as a response to Islamism and by
Islamism I mean the idea that in Islam
the idea that really came to power and
prominence in the 1970s but of course
dates back much longer that Islam holds
the answers to a variety of modern
contemporary questions that inspires the
Muslim Brotherhood and all other types
of political movements informed by Islam
so the Islamic Republic is arguably the
most spectacular and successful
instantiation of Islamism generating as
we all know Constitution systems of
governments etc but also culture so if
whether we consider ourselves to live in
an
mr. moment or a post Islamist moment as
Asif Fayed would would have us believe
we have Jen there is a increasing
attention within the scholarly community
and within among anthropologists of the
middle-east and Islam on the on the
prevalence of Pyatt pious cultures pious
Muslim cultures things like halal pop
the phenomenon of the hijabis etc right
so in reaction to some of that and and
also actually homage as laws talk is
also an example of that examination of
just relatively rare in Iran to examine
the efflorescence of religious cultural
formations that are both better popular
in nature so my question is related but
a little bit different so what about the
culture that comes after if secularism
can be said to produce Islamism what
does Islamism produce if we follow the
line of argumentation that's presented
here and one of my thoughts is that we
have can look to other places as well as
Iran to see what an emergent trend among
other populations and Iranians amah in
which Islamists have decentered the
previously dominant secular political
and cultural order so in addition to
Iran we can look to post-revolution
Egypt and erred once turkey but before I
go into thinking about this I thought I
would just start with a musical example
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so this is a song from the 1990
album Shaw gated that the top student
buy your favorite and mine the southern
california-based expatriate pop singer
and songwriter mr. Schad on the shot
patter
the song is called da da da da dee or a
veiled girl
schibetta presents us with a similar
scenario to that presented in patio or
other famous Japanese songs a more or
less innocent flirtation with a pretty
neighborhood girl rendered in a sort of
folksy folksy dialect but the somber
dramatic in a musical instant
introduction heavy with strings timpani
oboe gives us an aural clue to the
seriousness of this topic he speaks to
the neighborhood girl who wears a chador
the most pious of veils we're favored by
an Iranian woman he longs to see this
girl without her veil he knows she's
beautiful even by the bit of her that
she can see he asks to see her and she
refuses not in a flirtatious way but
with terrible fear and sadness again
emphasizing mistakes of this encounter
the girl eventually verbally acquiesce
is but puts him off in some distant
future she may let him have this a
glimpse of her quote moon-like Beauty
but that future has yet to come
shout Pat is frustrated how long until
he can appreciate this woman's beauty as
he so desires and then the dambulla
beats the synthesizers the chanting
vocals as the song transforms into
standard shop had a fare for moving
Iranian bodies on the dance floor as
they shake and shimmy to him singing
about wanting to a girl to take off her
hijab this song is I think for most of
us probably you can tell me later
transparently interpretable as an
objection to compulsory veiling when
shot pata says he doesn't mind veiling
but at the same time he does I hear him
struggling with tolerating the practice
an abstract when confronted with a woman
who in his portrayal is very unhappy
wearing the veil now it could be that
this conservatively veiled woman is sad
and frightened because a man to whom she
is not related is trying to get her to
take off her head covering in the middle
of the street but I suspect that we are
not supposed to generalize this
individuals the way that we are supposed
to end generalize this individuals
unhappiness availing to many if not all
women the presence of the dark cloud
covering the moon's beauty cliche is
also present in early 20th century
unveiling polemics and is reinvigorated
in Shaba abbey and other los angeles pop
singer songs criticizing the veil so
shad Patty is not the only one to have
an anti veiling pop song or critical
veiling pop song in such discourse the
veil is not expressive of religious
commitment or a means of liberating
women from the male gaze but a
patriarchal and after the Revolution
steeped in position from which women and
their physical beauty should be
liberated either by themselves or with
male assistants so we can tell right
away or I'm going to argue that we can
tell that shab pata is arguing with with
a pietistic relationship to Islam the
dance music itself and the fact that he
makes his profession from this is that
is a is another indication of his
orientation towards moralistic Muslim
piety not only as he's singing about
wanting a girl to don veil he is doing
so to music that accompanies the sexual
tension riddled interactions of
unrelated dancing males and females who
could be drinking alcohol consuming
drugs and eventually fornicating none of
this analysis is intended to cast
dispersions or make any assumptions
about shad pat his faith his
relationship to his long or his personal
piety nor am i saying that shad patty or
others creating similar works are aiming
to corrupt educate or liberate their
audiences through music though some have
accused them and/or lauded them for the
for these activities my name in this
analysis is instead to listen to Tara
Angeles through the moral filter to
consider them tan Angeles popular music
industry overall as sustained
transgressions of conservative forms of
moral personal comportment as conceived
in normative iranian post-revolutionary
Shiism i'm teasing out the idea that the
gulf that shadowy and talked to angeles
more generally can be places for
expressing culture after Islamism
cultural formations and products that
emerge - excuse me emerge from respond
to and present aesthetic and thematic
alternatives to Islamism
I think just to give you a different
example I was going to talk a lot but I
think I'm gonna give you another example
here then now this is a rather rare
example of direct address to religious
people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you didn't get it in Persian you'll
get him in English it's none of your GD
business right so okay so I didn't I
don't have a translation slide for this
but basically he's saying if you you
pious nellis ones people obsessed with
rule-following in Islam if you can't if
it's none of your business
if I want to be drunk if I want to chase
girls if I want to do any of that is
none of your business if you're on the
road to heaven and I'm on the road to
hell it's none of your business
so this is actually a secularist
orientation towards religion right he's
not saying down with the Prophet
Muhammad he's not saying any of those
things he's saying circumscribe your
religion to the point where you do not
impose on the public on my private or
public activities and in that kind of
this is at the same time this is a
rather nostalgic piece to me because of
the musical references because of the
style of speech and hearkens it's not
hard for me to imagine perhaps some of
you had similar visions passing through
your mind a scene in one of the few
Farsi Cabaret scenes of Ja hen sitting
and saying you know you know this kind
of action saying this is not this is
them so in a sense this kind of or we
can think about Hafiz as poems it's also
addressing ahead right so there's there
we we don't have to say that this is a
strictly post-revolutionary type of
complaint about religious intervention
in personal life but given the musical
references to a pre rebel very
particular pre-revolutionary Coffey II
kind of sound and given given the timing
in which this was released this is 2005
this particular and the fact that it's
released in Los Angeles outside of Iran
all help me think of it as part of a
larger phenomenon in which cultural
production is is is directed into
avenues that are opposing if not not set
on destruction but set on at least
opposing and presenting alternatives to
up specifically Islam Islamic for
and interventionist Islamist identity so
if there is an is and basically if there
is an Islamist culture then there is
also an anti or an unordered Islamist
culture which may yet be emergent but
will appear wherever the Islamist
culture is or was so sociologist
resolved Allah me has studied Iranians
in the UK and are used for what he calls
a pervasive non islami ASSA t doesn't
roll off the tongue but what he means is
specifically and powerfully anti Islamic
introduced Borak secularism I like full
armies work on this but he stops short
of thinking about about cultural
production because he doesn't really
address popular music and and we know
the reasons why popular music has been
particularly rich as a source of why it
was banned so quickly after the
Revolution why television wasn't for
instance in the same ways or why film
could be repurposed in a way that music
wasn't we just don't have 300 years of
Fed telling us that we can't watch TV
right so we have this there's this this
entrenched kind of moral mmm moral I'm
imagining it as fluff around music that
we have we have to deal with that it
makes it different from other types of
expressive culture though dance I would
also put there as well so I think before
we go too far into ideology I want to I
want to transition into a conversation I
had with a satellite television producer
who I'll call daddy in Los Angeles in
2007 where it became very clear that the
business model for satellite television
antenna Angeles in relation to Iran was
to provide Iranian audiences with
programming and advertising that
connected them with what they could not
get easily in the country so this
channel the man explained survives
solely on advertising revenue from both
Iranian and non Iranian companies
selling products either within Iran
itself or and obey where Iran ian's
could afford to who could afford to
travel might purchase foreign or luxury
goods or real estate the channel also
showed advertisements for products that
couldn't easily be marketed in iran
ali's example was hair dye which is
problematic because
showing a woman's uncovered face and
body would break local laws in Iran so
you've all probably seen hair dye being
sold with a woman's face marked out at
least that's what it was like a while
ago so this advertising revenue which he
said amounted to about two hundred
thousand dollars a month at best came as
a direct result of the fact that his
clients were happy with how successful
their products were within Iran so what
I asked was attracting Iran based
viewers to satellite television in the
first place how the example answer was
simple it was popular music he estimated
that music videos made up 60% of the
channels programming while it
represented nearly all the content on
other expatriate stations like PMC or or
Penn a person entertainment network like
the advertisements for hair dye this
success of expatriate to satellite
television within Iran rested on its
ability to provide the audience with
what they could not acquire locally or
maybe more accurately what people in Los
Angeles imagined that they could not
attain locally he explained his channels
appealed via a point by point comparison
with what Iranian state television could
offer to its Iran based viewers quote at
the end of the day music is the key
because the Iranian government cannot
compete with those of us in LA they have
a big budget for serials they have all
the access to sports we steal the feed
from them most of the time for the
sports and replay it on our Channel but
they have better access to sports and
more money for movies okay all the
movies made in Persian or in Iran the
only thing we've got is music a few
minutes later in our conversation he
offered clarification we are not better
than them in music because they cannot
have in anything except music because
they cannot have an D with ten
half-naked girls singing and dancing I
want to go to that because well
half-naked girl singing and dancing are
common in modern media culture the world
over at least comments indicate that
Tehran jealous pops economic value is
enhanced by official Iranian policies
especially compulsive veiling and limits
on social dance and women's public
singing which are intended to maintain
public spaces in public cultures
adhering to the state's definition of
Islamic morality it has always been
possible to profit from immoral or
impious products and experiences but
Iran's Islamist rants
formation turns what might have been
previously conceived as moral
transgressions into something much more
serious
when Ali's family arrived in Southern
California in the 1980s popular music
with or without half-naked girls was
itself one of the expatriate industries
immoral offerings but the intervening
decades of Iranian governmental agencies
and regulatory bodies permitting popular
music has changed that relationship as
Ali corrected himself above even in 2007
it was no longer true that tetra Julis
had pop music when Iran didn't as the
parameters of her official morality have
adjusted over time the economic openings
for for 10 Angeles cultural producers
have also shifted so one of the things
that remains durable is their ability to
to work with with half-naked women right
so this is this is one of the main
things that we still have another thing
that not you done how am i doing on time
yeah sure okay so another aspect of what
is being preserved in Los Angeles and
this is also common in in current Turkey
is sort of nostalgia for the modern era
so the idea that the Islamist movement
rate this is a bit of a fallacy to think
of Islamist movements as being hostile
to modernity but in an in a vision in
which in which secularists have imagined
that the modern world should be secular
than the appearance of religion can make
it seem as if time has gone backwards
somehow in Turkey there's a great a book
that's called nostalgia for that for the
modern that I've used to talk about Gugu
SH with so I'll let you follow up on
that yourself but I'll say that Los
Angeles is in some ways museum and a
graveyard literally for the
pre-revolutionary past where we have all
kinds of people buried in Los Angeles
right in downtown so it was probably
most of you know who that is and of
course we have Heidi and masty who are
also
right there along with the beginning and
Recordings themselves are a kind of dead
object that can be reinvigorating at
times so I want to in order to close I
want to think about women in particular
because I think this is as we have noted
several times over the course of the
conference
the woman question that one about 50% of
the population is the sticking point
right this is this is still where our
red line is so thinking again
comparatively and thinking about Egypt
so this is a this is a comment quote
that I'll read to you about the current
situation from media in Egypt and about
the economic value of uncovered women
and the way that having an Islamist
cultural sphere actually enhances the
economic value of nudity essentially so
from the perspective of economy says
Michael Frisch coffin at the
musicologist of Egypt contrasting rules
for female representations enables
highly profitable musical practices to
thrive in separate domains
despite Islamic discourse is deeply
critical of music the media system
depends on the maintenance of multiple
media worlds and we could internally
consonant apparently mutually
antagonistic and yet symbiotic while
religion and capitalism may appear
contradictory the pursuit of profit
versus higher principles their media
worlds are are mutually reinforcing I
want to think about Los Angeles being
reinforced by the Islamic Republic god
forbid that the government should ever
change their entire purpose could really
dissipate before their eyes but this
idea of synergy I don't want to be too
cynical about this because I think this
idea of synergy is really important so
extreme veiling and enhances the
economic value of the female body while
the unveiled body viscerally legitimizes
the social spiritual value of moral
virtue the apparent visible
contradiction between these worlds
thus conceals an unacknowledged synergy
by which each world maintains its
boundaries and so I think about that a
lot in terms of Los Angeles a lot in
terms of Los Angeles singers and a lot
in terms in particular of sepi there
seppia is one of our few Los Angeles
singers who has really put made to the
per body the center
performance so I want to read and I
would I should say that when I'm talking
about this sort of post Islamist space
I'm not always talking about things that
are as direct as what we what the two
examples that I showed you before so I
have never heard anybody referred to say
as a Han and a se hace political singer
she has but she has at times deployed a
language of feminist emancipation
through sexuality that has specific
resonances given the transnational
post-revolutionary cultural context in
which her technologically mediated voice
and image are produced so in a Facebook
post from 2014 sepia described herself
as a strong sexy proud yet independent
Persian woman unbound by any tat taboo
and breaking away from the previously
perceived female image in Iran that has
always been the victim throughout Iran's
post Islamic history
she continues I am a part of all the
proud and strong Persian women who show
the world that we are not less than any
man and can do all they do and more
herself designation of as Persian rather
than Iranian I think most of us
understand where that comes from the
recourse to mythical pre-revolution or
pre-islamic history in which women and
men were imagined to be more equal but
really hurt her hurt taboo breaking
behavior which I think here refers to
her revealing clothing and erotic
performances as emancipatory once again
puts puts the puts the female body right
in the center of these kinds of in these
kinds of struggles so if we look again
to to Egypt and I'm just gonna warn you
there's gonna be a naked woman on the
screen okay so everybody just get ready
okay here we are you ready
so alia Magda almighty is an Egyptian
activists who took a picture of herself
in her bedroom the one with her wearing
the stockings and it went on Facebook
and Twitter and and it was during in the
aftermath of the of the 2011 revolution
in Egypt and this became a problem for
her right I mean obviously but the body
itself becomes the site of expressing
these kinds of of opposition and for her
you know Shia is not a constitution and
she's surrounded by other women in the
second picture which is in I believe
that picture was taken in Germany but
may have been Sweden where she was
living the body becomes very central to
this kind of expression and we don't see
that you know we were talking about
societal constraints versus political
constraints and so on in Los Angeles
land of the free home of the brave we
could have many more half-naked Iranian
women singing and dancing on television
than we do
we don't though because on some level
that's also a conservative because
there's a price to pay for that and the
price the price can be very high that
kind of activism has been another naked
woman coming has been more the avenue of
cultural elites and people who can
actually do this and transcend and not
be marked by it right in mark not be
marked by it in this sense of be of
their immediate professional networks of
course closest the federal money has
also paid for for her own activism in
this sense but the body becomes a site
of this kind of activism because the
female form is open to these
interpretations in the in the Islamist
in the reaction to Islamism so you're
gonna get a very strange slide next
because I thought this talk was going to
be different that's not what you should
see I am going to wrap it up
I'm going to wrap it up here and just
say in closing that my sort of exercise
in looking outside of Iran immediately
both looking to diaspora and looking to
comparative examples as part of what
really interests me in in doing the work
and as much as I truly do appreciate the
in-depth research that's being done on
Iran and the research that we've been
able to share with each other in this
very unique situation I also think that
there's something to be gained from
looking beyond the Iranian situation and
beyond what it is what is easy to think
of as a very exceptional situation in
fact I think our case has much to offer
as many of the world's populations
grapple with different types of regime
changes and political movements informed
by Islam and after all we are the
vanguard in that area so thank you
[Applause]
okay I'll be connected any questions for
the experience of diaspora you grow
apart from the homeland and do so this
does begin to grow
[Music]
I did a lot of discussions happening
around the law some this is critique of
the way things are happening in Iran and
this secular nationalism that will
pervade in Los Angeles and north the
discussions that usually surround these
things and happen in the kind of more
private spheres
I mean it's impossible right now talk
about secular Iranian nationalism
without talking about anti-arab racism
and that's also something that's also
encroaching in Iran but in a different
way was propagated by the regime I'm
also influenced by it Los Angeles that
can have potentially very dangerous so I
may be talking about that and another
thing that also been thinking about is a
lot of the times in these kind of Los
Angeles productions
I understand how said Vida is kind of
functioning in this
kind of Western feminists um discourse
but at the same time a lot of the other
percussion productions in Los Angeles
don't seem to be functioning on feminist
values but rather exploitation of women
most of the time not Iranian with me and
goes up black and brown and diverse
women baby talking yeah I'm gonna think
about your second question first because
I already forgot the first one so you
can yeah oops okay I'm thinking about
the protection of the virtue of Iranian
women by substituting brown and white
other women right and how that's
something that Professor Shea has talked
about in terms of dance performances and
when you you know it's this funny thing
where you watch the dancer backup the
backup dancers in a lot of these videos
who can tell immediately that they
aren't Iranian by the way that they move
if you can't tell by the way that they
look one of the more interesting things
one of the people who I had the most
interesting conversations with about the
dynamics of being a woman in the music
industry was with shafts upon Lu who has
tried very hard to carve out a space for
herself that it was neither video vixen
it's basically don't that at home is
trying to be is trying to be a good good
girl especially in the early part of her
career now it's a little bit different
so and she may be as an exception a
little bit to what you're saying but I
think it because you're talking about
the question that you had was about
women who are embracing exploitation or
for instance using exploitation I think
it would be very easy to make that
argument about
that be there as well one Facebook post
is not an activist meet right you know
on the other hand I think that what I'm
trying to do is is be a little bit more
circumspect about how we think about
nudity you know and sexual kind of
sexuality and whether or not and and
maybe whether things can be both and all
at the same time this is sort of a third
wave feminism Tyre second you know third
may feminism type of idea that we can
both be proud of our sexuality and be
activists and choose to exploit
ourselves or choose to profit from our
own bodies and those those kinds of
decisions are very hard for Iranians
you're honoring women to make and
they're hard for all kinds of money but
they're hard even even in diaspora I
mean I don't want to make any
assumptions about where it's easier or
harder to be to do these kinds of things
but I think I'll think about about that
more tell me huh anti-arab racism yeah I
thought about doing a lot of my videos
when you know pictures of people with
pre-islamic imagery on their baseball
hats in their in their motorcycles and
stuff like that this sort of mythology
of the Aryan pure Aryan past and so on
yeah it's a real it's a real problem
and um I think that it's at the same
time the the conversation in Los Angeles
around Iranian identity and particularly
around Islam is also complicated by the
fact that there's a very large
percentage of religious minorities so
that Islam really if we think about I'm
gonna I'm gonna bracket the Arab issue
for a second but in a sense there's a
more diverse there's a very diverse
creation of Iranian identity that has to
accept Powys has to has to have how to
set be jewish your onions or austrians
christians armenians you know etc
everybody all together so there is a way
in which there's this revival /
continuity of
Shaw era nationalism that is quite
racist that people promulgate at the
same time there is this other side of it
that is more complicated or maybe
they're the same side anyway thanks for
the question I wonder if there's any
continuity between